so kim kardashian recently turned 40
years old
and kanye got her um a special gift
where he had somebody record a you see
holograms as her father i watched the
hologram and they wrote the script out
for him where kanye wrote
a genius kanye wrote the script and he's
like he's going through everything
you're like oh this is sweet and then
she and then he's like
and oh you're gonna yeah play this right
it's like two more only kanye would do
make it about
him happy birthday kimberly
look at you you're 40 and all grown up
how crazy is this you look
beautiful just like when you were a
little girl
i watch over you and your sisters and
brother and the kids
every day sometimes i drop hints that
i'm around
like when you hear someone make a big
peepee is that a fart
i think it's a fart you make a big pifi
so kanye wrote that drive you to school
mercedes every day and we would listen
to this song together
[Music]
i am so proud of the woman that you've
become kimberly
and all that you've accomplished all of
your hard work and all the businesses
you've
built are incredible but most impressive
is your commitment to become a lawyer
and carry on my legacy
it's a long and a hard road it looks so
real huh it looks
so with you every step of the way deep
fakes are getting so good now
the way that you're connecting with your
roots supporting armenia means so much
to me
you are a proud armenian and i am a
proud armenian father
the most beautiful thing that i have
witnessed is watching you grow your
family
you married the most most most most
most genius man in the whole world oh my
god i knew what i mean you missed it
about him that was kind of funny
you but he said dead serious he's way
he's serious the holograms that are dead
he's in the other team he can't
he wasn't just any lawyer he was o.j
simpson's lawyer
oh that's one of them but you know
what's weird is he was not a practicing
lawyer
when he jumped on oj's team he was
retired for years
he was in the music industry and then
because he was so close to oj
he decided to help oj out because they
were best friends
dang that's crazy yeah crazy then they
said oj is khloe kardashian dead
that's just [ __ ] i mean people
talking [ __ ] but oj did say he had sex
with uh
uh chris jennings yeah he said uh he had
sex with her
in a hot tub and apparently like he like
ripped her vagina or something she
to go to the hospital she woke him up in
the middle of the night
saying that he need she needs him to
take her to the er because she didn't
want to wake up her then husband rob
yeah and he was like no i'm not going to
take you so
she made rob take her to the er and
apparently nothing was the same after
that
oj said this that's what oj said chris
hello twitter world why would you look i
i believe o.j
why would he lie he
i don't think that i believe him for
that but y'all don't believe me when he
didn't say he did it
he didn't it's just too obvious he
didn't do it he did it it's just it just
everything stacks up that he did it
like all the evidence i mean that's have
you looked in the case
no i hit my black belt on the case he
said he got a black belt in the case
i'm obsessed would you want a hologram
of someone that you lost
um like that no because i know it's fake
and then someone else is right my brain
goes elsewhere i'm like yeah
who's wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah and like
it's not organic it's not real it'll be
too weird yeah yeah like the only one i
do is my uncle pax but like
whoever wrote it it would just i just
like got this off yeah yeah it's all
fair it's not real
yeah i couldn't do that if a hologram of
my brother popped up what should i do
i'd be like what the [ __ ] it'd be
awkward it'd be so awkward i'm like
what the [ __ ] and you know somebody
wrote the whole yeah
trying to like inside jokes yeah i'm
like yeah we knew he was like like when
like let's say he didn't call it pfes
like like when you rip a big fart
i'm around or when anybody rips a big
fart i'm around
who the [ __ ] wrote this yeah why do they
make it about farts
that's weird right yeah there's no way
in hell though you should just because
when somebody rips the big p
fee i'm around now don't you ruin that
tupac and easy hologram that [ __ ] was
tight well they rapping
and we don't yeah that was like actually
pretty cool like i think that's
you'd go to a concert and pay for that
no if it's part
of the show like it wasn't like a major
part of the street i mean there was a
talk about having concerts where it is
the
hologram tupac's classics and he's on
stage as a holiday yeah i probably
wouldn't do that
you could just play his music and like a
venue and i'd be like hell yeah
well hold on travis scott had like a uh
a
hologram when it was a lockdown and it
was on that uh
well that was a hug that was just that
the the video game the video game it was
the whole
game called fortnite yeah
yeah but can you imagine a full-blown
concert with a hologram yeah i couldn't
do that
too but i like the way they did it for
tupac where was just like what would you
guys
did like two songs peep this would you
go to nirvana concert if it's all the
band the real band
but kurt cobain's the lead singer and
he's the hologram but the real guys are
in the band
that's kind of actually that's going to
be hard actually i saw them do a reunion
a nirvana
they did it without kurt obviously that
guess singers but like the
surviving members of the band they did
like a reunion what was that what was
that big
2018 like dave grohl he wasn't in the uh
in the documentary
you know that the big hbo documentary
have you seen that uh i forget the name
of it
oh the kirk yeah because that was just
strictly about kurt cobain yeah he but
he refused one of the only members who
refused to be in it
oh yes we're going to yeah because he
doesn't think he commits suicide he
thinks he was murdered
i mean i mean like you said evidence the
evidence
black belt never brown bell i'd say
brown belt three strike brown but yeah i
think kirk okay i think he was murdered
oh yeah i mean this is an interesting
subject like kurt when you ask
when you look at it yes dave girl he's
like nah he was never suicidal a lot a
lot of his friends do say like he was
never suicidal was osborne
from uh the melvin oh i know you talking
about the white boy
they're all white yeah what the the
white boy with the dark hair
no buzz born he's got a fro
well like but all what am i talking
about but also you know the
you know dave the band you know the band
and uh kurt weren't talking for a while
when he committed suicide there was a
rift between them wait what
oh i don't think it was like that heavy
they just weren't talking though yeah
not like yeah i don't think it was like
a super falling out i think no he was
just
they just needed they wanted to take it
because they were like just they just
blew up so quick
so you know what i mean like when when
never mind dropped it was just like
an explosion even kurt cobain's daughter
thinks uh
he was murdered oh you hang out with her
no because that's what she said in an
interview
oh she did yep oh she said it like
literally in the interview i just enjoy
the music
that's a lot to put in my brain just
like to think about all like that
really it's dope yeah the bruce lee
one's a little shady too
bruce when you look in the bruce lee
stuff then
yeah bruce lee that you stole from his
gravesite
uh yeah bruce lee's where the like
he died from aspirin he's allergic to
aspirin like i guess i buy that
and then his son he's at his side pieces
house yeah that's weird
wait wait so i didn't know bruce lee had
a conspiracy to his death
no they think the triad did it right
what
he got shot and died that's how he died
and they said i know that but like but
they think someone did like did that on
purpose yeah on purpose really
which also i kind of believe if you've
ever been on set like what the how they
deal with guns or
be tough to put real bullets in again
yeah you have to go through so many
different people
yeah and there's people on set
specifically for
i think they call it like professional
gun department people it's so strict
like
in my my show yeah when you do the dude
out of ak-47 and like they were all over
me blanks right like as soon as i get
done they grab it
like they don't [ __ ] around oh really oh
god did they grab you
no they didn't grab me they would grab
the gun like this like this
i mean maybe it was a little more
loosey-goosey back then in the early 90s
but i don't know
but yeah you know oh really yeah
deliberately they they
didn't know anything about the bruce lee
thing i thought he died from yeah like
i'll send you some literature
i thought he had an aneurysm no it's
like a reaction to medication that he
didn't wake up either or something
wasn't feeling good so he went to this
house and they gave him an aspirin they
said he was allergic to asparagus
like come on man but they don't think
that's it what's what's what's twelve
plus twelve what what
yeah why why would people wanna kill him
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son